[Music]
good morning everyone or afternoon or
evening depending on where you are
relied you could join us for a
reproducible reporting the second in a
three-part series on the central tool
for data science with our I'm Roger
Oberg with our studio marketing and with
me on the call today are Jeff Allen uhj
Kevin you she and jjl air today's
session is being recorded and all
registrants will get an email saying
where to find it
when it is ready the webinar will last
approximately 50 minutes with ten
minutes for questions to submit a
question at any time during the webinar
please send it to organizers and
panelists or send questions to panelists
from your chat before we begin I'd like
you to be aware of additional
opportunities to learn from our studio
besides the last webinar in the series
on September 3rd in September Hadley
wickham is teaching the second media
two-day master our workshop in New York
City although we just actually sold that
out last week so fortunately we will be
opening up registration on Hadleys next
class soon which will be in San
Francisco on Jarek January 19th and 20th
if that interests you you can fill out a
form on our public workshop page and
we'll let you know when registration is
open in October Hadley jfe way Kevin and
JJ will offer in-person tutorials at our
day at strata also in New York City you
can find out more about these events on
our website so with that I'm very
pleased to turn things over to Jeff
Allen thanks all right so I want to talk
today about the next generation of our
markdown which is a package that has
been available for a couple years now
but over the past couple months we've
really overhauled it and added a lot of
interesting features so before we dig
into deep I'll just introduce you to
markdown if you're not from there
so markdown was they defined it as a
plain text formatting syntax but the
idea is that you're really just typing
in plain text
and that is going to render to more
complex formats so if you ever created a
txt file then you've already you've
already done half the battle really the
this the format allows you to focus on
you know it's really more primarily just
on creating the content that you want to
write without having to worry about the
formatting and the markup and things
like that
but what's what's great about this is
that you can just write your text you
know just focus on the content and then
later render that to HTML or PDF or some
other format and so our markdown as a
package that allows you to do this from
within our so market home just as an
example here are a few things that you
know with markdown conventions so again
you're just you're just typing normal
text primarily most of the time but if
you want to do different levels of
headers you can do those you can create
bold things you can create hyperlinks or
lists or tables so the power is there if
you do want to create these more complex
formats but typically it allows you just
to focus on the content rather than
needing to worry about you know making
sure that everything styles correctly
and flowing correctly all right so the
our markdown then is it's kind of a
package in the in the realm of literate
programming and the idea is that rather
than embedding comments in a string of
code that you have that instead you
would actually embed the code within the
document that you're writing and so you
can write kind of this narrative and you
know sort of great this prose that
describes the analysis that you're doing
and then within that just embed joints
of our code and obviously there a
variety of different ways that you can
that you can leverage the tool but
that's one of the more popular ones we
see in terms of reproducible research
and literate programming but the idea is
that you're going to render the textual
output and a graphical output and
anything else that are is creating you
know just inline within your document so
this is an example here so on the left
you can see that this would be the input
format so there's this convention of
three back ticks and then you specify
that using the our language and then in
here you just write any our code that
you want and then you close that with
three more back tags and what that would
render is what you see on the right here
so you would see that you have your
input commands
and you can see those just match the
first two lines of your input and then
any output that's textual here so when
you run length X you get the output here
which is 100 and then afterwards we do
hist acts to produce the histogram and
you can see as well that the image is
just going to be embedded directly in
your your document or your slideshow or
whatever it is you're creating so this
is a really easy way for you to you know
work with your analysis and a format
that you want to share with someone who
may not be comfortable running your code
themselves okay so I had mentioned that
the are marked unpackage has actually
been Omaha been around for a while and
so this was primarily the old workflow
of is that you had our from our town
that would render to markdown and then
we used a tool called sundown to create
HTML and you can actually create a lot
of type of PDF out of this as well but
but it was kind of more simplified
pipeline but until we can excuse me show
a quick example of what that looks like
so this is just an example our mark on
file I have you can see again most of
it's just text like I had explained
before you know we have some special
formatting we have a couple of our
chunks here and then we're doing
actually a couple more advanced features
but I won't go into the syntax --'tis
but just so that you can see that they
are possible here you can do la textile
equations you can do footnotes you can
do all sorts of things like that but
again primarily the focus is just on
creating prose and embedding your our
code within that so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to knit that document to
HTML and you can see what that's going
to produce so this is an HTML file it
happens to be shown in this arc studio
viewer but you know we could open this
up in an extra from a browser we could
share it soon didn't be email whatever
we want to do and you can see that all
the conventions that we created in our
markdown document hyperlinks fold any
commands that we executed of the output
of those commands even any equations or
footnotes with hyperlinks you know are
all produced tables and even graphical
output from your code so
it's a really powerful tool just to
create HTML files but that was primarily
how the old version was used but now as
of the latest overhaul we actually have
a variety of different formats that you
can very easily get into including
Microsoft Word and so I can show a
couple of examples here
okay so knitting to PDF again has been
has been possible before but just for
you that it works again you get the
equations format it as you'd expect you
get footnotes you get tables all the
things that we were seeing previously
you get in PDF as well but then even
more impressive is that all these things
actually work in Microsoft Word as well
and so if you are fortunate or
unfortunate enough depending on your
perspective to need to work with
Microsoft Word then you can you can
easily now create documents while you
know working with tools that aren't
they're a little more streamlined and
efficient but they ultimately produce
documents that you can share with other
collaborators so you may want to use
Microsoft Word so and again as you can
see all of the conventions that we've
been using actually work there's an
editable Microsoft Word equation in here
that represents an equation that you
produce again you have your input your
output your images tables that you can
actually go in and edit resize and do
things that you want to do with so don't
alright so many of the output formats
are already defined so you we've shown
you that you can do Microsoft Word ease
into HTML you can do bas vector PDF but
you can also the entire system is
pluggable meaning that you can actually
define a custom forma and render your
output into that format if you if you so
desire I'll show you the documentation
for that at the end of we're not gonna
actually go through that exercise just
for the sake of time today but what's
interesting about this is that you can
create output formats that are entirely
novel so if HTML or Word or PDF are
cutting it for you you can actually
create entirely new output formats or
just modify existing formats so for
instance if you you know are happy with
the HTML that you want your company CSS
stylesheet applied to it
or something that sort then we can
certainly do that so I'll show you just
an example again not of creating the the
element but of you know perhaps if your
company had certain CSS styling that you
wanted or a certain image header or
something like that perhaps you have a
certain you know scaffolding that you
want to provide around all the documents
that you produce you know we can we can
certainly do that so just as an example
I've created a a new output format
that's still if I go to our markdown or
whether or not the template when I go to
our markdown from template you can see
that I created this package Jeff package
and it has a new template within it so
you can imagine that your company you
know could could invest one time in
producing these artifacts and then you
know allow other users to share them
within the convenience of our markdown
so this is the template that I defined
in my in my template and you can see you
know perhaps you always need to end your
documents with the conclusion in this
company or if you had a certain journal
that you were submitting to and they had
certain style guides for you know what
sections you should provide you can do
that but what's neat about this is that
within my template I've specified that
there's a certain CSS style sheet that I
want to be to be applied and you can see
this does not look like the original
HTML document that I produced the rather
it has different colors and different
fonts and things I thought so you can
imagine that this could be you know
styled for your company and or you know
your personal personal use of people for
different styling so that's very easy to
do and again I'll give you the link at
the very end that that shows you how you
would go about creating your own
then also you have custom formats and so
again that's a little bit outside of the
scope of what we're going to cover today
but I'll just show you a couple examples
once that we've already produced so if
you've worked with Beamer which is a la
tech presentation format that's
historically been kind of difficult
because you have to write a lot typed by
hand what's great about this is that our
markdown since it can render latte it
can actually render Beamer as well once
we've defined the Beamer template which
we've already done for you
and again this is full-fledged our
markdown so you can do you can embed our
codes you can embed images and do all
the things that you're used to doing our
markdown and then at the end go to
native PDF and you get this beamer
document that has all the content that
you're expecting in it but without
having to go through the headache of
learning la tech or you know even if you
know that sometimes using it can be a
bit painful and so you know this allows
you just to to continue working with our
markdown a very convenient and efficient
and streamlined format but you can
produce very rich and complex
outperformance and then also we have
different HTML slide templates the
slides that I'm using right now are
actually they've the i/o slides template
that were produced in our work done
alright and then kind of a the last
example here you can really go all the
way with this and create you know entire
templates that really define the entire
structure of what you want to do so you
may you know peaked at this when I was
showing that previous template but if
you were submitting to JSS or you're
submitting to use our or something of
that sort then you can really you know
you can define a template that you can
continue to reuse and so if you envision
yourself submitting to a journal
frequently or even if you're just
submitting once it may be worth the time
to create this output template for you
so again this is a use our submission
template and you can see that we have
you know all the basic amount stuff that
we've been using up till now but what's
interesting now is that we've actually
were using a bibliography now as well
and by providing this references section
that's going to encapsulate all of the
references
that we've defined here and we're using
in this case we're just using a big tech
format but it actually supports a wide
variety of different bibliography
formats that you can use so but we'll
just show you this example here so if I
go to knit I'm gonna get a PDF of my use
our submission and you can see that it
actually popularized the argue peas for
me it puts Isis citations it does all
these things that that I would want it
to do and so if you're submitting you
sorry this is a very easy way to do it
but but also if you're submitting just
some journal that has certain
conventions you know or certain lot X
Files sheet or something like that
this is know much easier way to interact
with them okay and then the last point
here just to make this kind of a teaser
I won't go into a whole lot of detail in
this but is that now when you're using
the HTML format you can actually support
interactivity so if you're familiar with
the shiny package that allows you to do
kind of interactive web analysis within
our if I go to our markdown and I click
shiny I can create a shiny document or
shiny presentation we'll just do a shiny
document for now but any presentations
are actually kind of fun because you can
imagine that you're using an HTML style
or an HTML slideshow but in the middle
of your presentation you have some
interactive element that you can go in
and kind of dig dig into in the middle
of your presentation which is kind of a
fun something to be able to do so you
can see here that this is just an R
markdown document but if you're familiar
with shiny you'll recognize some of
these functions here it was a very easy
way to get into shiny and there's really
no overhead or boilerplate that's
required but when I go to run this
document I'll save it first and when I
got to run this document you'll see that
it's a regular our markdown document
just like we've seen before but now it
also has shiny interactive components
and so when I go through and I you know
toggle these different you know widgets
that I can play with I'm able to to
change all these things interactively
within my arm arctan document this is a
really great way if you if you you know
kind of envision that you're creating a
large like static document but there are
little pieces where you want to add some
interactivity then this is a really nice
way to be able to do that
okay so finally here are a couple of
resources and we'll make these slides
and everything else available to you
online afterwards but this would be the
best resource for our markdown here's
our markdown hqda calm that will have
all the details that you need about
creating custom templates custom formats
anything you'd want to create and then
the slides from the works they available
here as well
the one trick here is that you'll
probably want to download the latest
version of our studio so just for your
convenience to make it easier to use all
these things now again if I didn't
mention this before our mark on is an
open source for either available our
package it's downloadable from cran and
so you're certainly welcome to use this
from any our editing environment they
choose
it's just that in our studio we've kind
of done the work to make some of these
things a little more convenient in terms
of you know just adding some buttons for
you and kind of simplifying things great
well that will be all that I have in
terms of our markdown today I'll
obviously be available at the end for
any questions that may pop up but
otherwise I'll go ahead and pass control
off to the geek way
we'll take a little deeper into mid are
all right everyone so today I'm going to
talk about the narrower package and you
might be wondering what this title
actually means and the images that came
too much came to your mind might be like
this or like this
but actually that's not what I'm going
to talk about today and I gave this talk
at the use our conference this year and
if you are interested in that talk you
can go to this github repository and
find find the slides over there and for
that use our talk I assumed that you
know the basics of mirror but for this
talk I'm not going to make that
assumption so it would be a very basic
introduction to the knitter package and
the the real image for this talk is this
little ninja
and so a little bit about the motivation
for reproducible research and you when
you do a data analysis so many of many
of you might be doing analysis like this
so you first you write some code in your
favorite programming language like R and
then you do some computing and you copy
and paste results into your favorite
editor like make Microsoft Word or latex
or things like that so you just keep on
pressing ctrl C and control V to copy
and paste the results and the problem
with that approach for doing data
analysis is that whenever you you find a
mistake in your date source or you want
to change a parameter in your report
then you will end up doing the same
thing that you just did maybe last week
so your life would be like this you just
repeat whatever it did from last week
and do all the things like clicking the
buttons and copying the results and
pasting that into it into words so you
certainly don't want to repeat the
things so the the key solution for that
problem is that you want to automate
your analysis instead of manually
copying and pasting new results so to
automate your analysis tasks you can use
this idea of dynamic documents so the
basic idea is that data analysis report
is basically a combination of your
program code with some narratives to
explain what your code is doing here
so here is a very simple example we
compose first we write some narratives
like we build a linear regression model
and then we continue writing this report
with some man code so for example here I
build a linear regression model and
assign that to this object fit and then
I extract
the coefficients using the wave function
in in R and so this would be a vector of
coefficients for this in your model and
then I draw some plus or the for the
regression Diagnostics and then I
continue paragraph and writing that the
slope of this work regression is this so
normally you will see a number here for
example the slope is 3 point 1 2 or
something like that which is hard-coded
but here I don't hard-coded the number
here I dine a mcclee dynamically extract
the number from this efficient vector
and when I compile this document the
code will be run the plots will be drawn
and numbers will be written in the final
output so this is dynamic in terms of we
want to change certain things in the in
the code the output will be
automatically updated so there's nothing
that you want to copy and paste so all
the output will be generated
automatically so to do that you you need
to install this package knitter using
the function in your store actus or and
optionally you may want you may or may
not want to install the our studio
environment but later I will demonstrate
some examples you in the our studio
environment so for this talk about
basically folks on an example for
homework so for the for this homework
assignment so you have some code chunks
and you have some narratives explaining
what your task is in this homework
example here we were asked to find the
genes that should be identified as
differentially expressed it doesn't
matter if you don't understand that what
that means an annual way you would just
you read some data into the your our
session for example the data set is over
here is just it just consists of a bunch
of numbers so you scan that file into
your our session your sets and
parameters in the beginning for example
the Alpha level to be 0.05 then you draw
a power plot and then you do some
analysis and you also you may also want
to explain what what the methods are so
for example the bomb for our newest
methods or the Holmes method or Benjamin
Hodge firk method methods and using
these methods in youth then you continue
processing your data and draw some
conclusions in the end and we identified
these genes to be differentially
expressed using this method in this
genes using that method so this is a
dynamic document and when we want the
output we just click this button called
knit HTML in the in our studio and then
the output will be automatically
generated over here so we have a title
for this report author dates narratives
in code when you scan the data into R
you can print these these values and
when you draw a power plus using the
power of functioning in base R you will
see a bar plot over here and we have set
the Alpha level here to be 0.05 and
that's where this red line is so this is
0.05 and we explain these methods using
some math expressions and we have a few
more sections and you do that to do the
analysis and finally we draw some
conclusions for example we identify the
gene number one using this method engine
number one using Holmes method and the
genes 1 to n 10 using the pan-german in
Hochberg method and just in case you
want to change
I'm interested for this record for
example I want to raise the Alpha level
from 0.05 to for example 0.2 and then if
you don't use this approach of dynamic
documents then you have you will have to
run the code again and generate a report
a generator generate a plot and paste
that plot into your editor environment
but if you use this idea of dynamic
documents you just need to click a
button and everything will just be
updated for example the Alpha level has
been raised from 0.05 to 0.2 and the
power plot is automatically updated and
your conclusions has also been updated
for example originally here it was the
only the gene one and now we identify
the chains one two and ten so the
results are changed in this document so
it's just a few minutes ago there was
one person in the audience who asked the
question about how to hide the code and
the answer is that you can use some
chunk options for example here I use
echo equals false that basically means I
want to hide the code in the output I
only want to show the output for this
code chunk so here you only see the
output for example here is a a chunk of
text output and here is the graphics
output so by using echo equals false you
can hide the results and there are some
other options that you might be
interested in for example I want to do
the the computing but for this code
chunk I don't want to show you the
results so you can use the chunk option
results equals height and that basically
means okay I want to run this code chunk
but I don't want to show the text output
so you see when you print the p-values
the the printed output is actually
hidden here
so there are many many other options
that you can use if you if you are in
our studio you can just hit the tab key
to do some other completions there are
there are a whole bunch of chunk options
that you might want to use and you will
you will find the documentation for all
these chunk options on the knitter
website okay Peter so and that's how we
can play with a text out code and
actually you can also example change the
parameters for graphics output for
example here the the size of this plot
is like five by seven inches so I if I
want to make this plot taller so I can
specify the chunk option figure figure
dot height equals ten which means the
height will be ten inches if I change
the size all I need to do is just click
this button again and the output will be
after it so there are some other chunk
options associated with graphics output
for example the device option so you can
use a bunch of graphics devices like the
ng device Hoover has VG device in many
others so this is how you can play with
the graphics output and sometimes your
code chunk might be time consuming so
let me just show you a quick example of
how you can deal with that situation so
if your code chunk is time consuming you
can actually use the chunk option cache
because true so when you turn on this
chunk option the results will be cached
so you see when I click this button arts
video will pass for five seconds here
and then show me in the output and now
the second time when I click this button
if I don't change the code here
then Nero will just load the odd results
from the cache database directly into
the our session and show you the output
so now you can see the output
immediately instead of waiting for five
seconds here so that's the feature for
cash and let's see what else and also if
you don't want to use the our language
you know your code chunks you can also
use some other languages using the chunk
option engine so for example here is
Python code chunk so I just need to
specify the chunk option engine it goes
Python and then I will be able to I will
be able to run the disco chunk using
Python instead of R so when I click this
button and our will launch Python key to
split this character string into a
vector here of three elements there are
some other chunk options that can also
work with the option engineer cost
Python there are some other languages
supported in in nature of example you
can use our CPP to write some C++ code
so all you have to do is to specify
engine it goes our CPP and now now you
just write some CP C++ code similarly
just click this button and neither will
compile this C++ code chunks and show
you the results in the output and so
these are just some very basic features
of the inator package and you can also
have some applications using the Nero
package and one application is that you
can build websites using knitter and for
example this website are stupidly
calorie is built on you using knitter
and our CPP so you can see this is
basically like
a blog site so there are a couple of
posts seems the internet connection is
not good here but yeah early you can
check out by yourself later and it's
basically this is based on our markdown
and there are some plus coach Hank Cindy
in the blog posts and you can compile
all these blog posts using knitter and
there's also another website called our
pops calm so that basically contains a
lot of HTML documents compared from from
knitter so for example here is a peer
assessment project one I'm not sure if
that's there from the Coursera course or
some something else but basically you
can see the code chunks and the graphics
and things like that and to publish to
this website you can actually click this
button in our studio called publish so
if you have if you have registered on
our part outcome you can upload your
reports to that website and there are a
lot of other excellent examples on this
website you can check out later by
yourself another application of mirror
is that you can write your package
Ronettes if you are a package author so
basically here is the the source code
for the for the knitter package and I
have a directory called vignettes and
then I have a couple of our markdown
documents under this directory and to
write package vinius using knitter you
just need to specify the vignette engine
to be a certain engine in Internet our
package and then you specify the title
for this vignette and when you compare
this pack package and then you start it
you will see a list
vignettes like like this so here are the
beauty in vignettes in the middle
package so I just want to show you one
of them which is the this one called the
toggle classic style this is a very
interesting layout in my eyes so for
this layout you can see the narratives
and the code and the output are arranged
side-by-side so if you want hided code
you can just press the key T on your
keyboard so you can just read it the
narratives and graphics output and if
you want to hide the narratives if you
get you you don't you don't care about
narratives you just want to read a code
it can hide the narratives and just read
the code and for most people probably
this is side by side layout is most
appropriate so this is how you can play
with the dark whole style you nearer so
there are a couple of resources to learn
more about standard internet or the
first one I wanted to recommend is just
the online documentation for this
package they're just at you wait dot
name slash Nader and if we if you're
just too rich you can just buy this book
I wrote last year dynamic documents with
our and knitter but you don't really
have to buy that one because I have very
comprehensive documentation for this
package online so just a last comment on
reproducible research which is the
target for today so reproduce where
research is really not a trivial thing I
mean there are a lot of things to
consider when you write a report just
just by using knitter does not guarantee
that your report is reproducible for
example you may you might be using some
absolute paths in your reports which
will not be reproducible on other
peoples in computers or and then there
are just a lot of things to consider and
but I guess knitter will be helpful as
at least as the first step to reproduce
research and I just hope all of you can
be
patient enough to wait for this area of
reproach reproducible research to grow
just like this tree and finally you
would hopefully you will be we will be
living in a wonderful world of
reproducible research all right thank
you I will hand over to you Kevin
okay thank you it alright so now I'm
going to talk about pack bread which is
a dependency management system for our
so given everything that Jeff and EJ
have taught us about trying to write
reproducible research one thing that we
want to be able to do is take the our
environment that we use to produce these
reports and try and preserve that over
time so pakrats is an r package that
helps us manage these our projects our
package dependencies in a way that is
reproducible so when you form an
analysis you're going to use different
our packages say you got them from cran
or if you live on the bleeding edge
maybe you got them from github but when
you do an analysis or write in our
project you want to make sure that you
can save these packages over time say
you published us as research and one or
two years down the line you need to run
that again you want to make sure you can
reproduce that exact same results with
the exact same environment that you used
originally when forming the analysis
another thing about this is you want
your projects to be isolated so in the
current state of the art world when you
install a package it goes into your
global library so every project that you
write on your computer has access to
that package and that's often useful in
some occasions you want to be able to
have a private library for each project
in case one project depends on one
version of a package and another project
depends on another version of the
package so pakrac gives you a means of
isolating these package dependencies
within a library for each project and
last of all we want this to be portable
so that
if you need to collaborate with people
on alternative machines they can build
the same our environment using the same
system from your packrat project so
packrat makes it easy to install those
packages for a particular art project
part of the reason why we why the
packrat devotin was motivated is for
those of you who have either been in
research for a while or done some work
and come back to it a year later
you've probably come back to your code
and asked first of all who wrote this
garbage code unfortunately one of the
side effects of becoming a better
programmer is realizing that the code
you wrote before is probably not as good
and unfortunately if you come back to
code a year later you know unless you
wrote it in a reproducible nicely
commented way you're gonna struggle to
recollect exactly what you did and how
you did it another thing is you might
have used save lattice which is an r
package for generating plots use that to
make some figures before but now when
you try to run it with your new version
of RSA you updated it recently all of a
sudden you're plotting code is just
throwing errors at you for some reason
lattice update has broken your code and
you know your code didn't change but
lattice did so now you have to figure
out what changed and how you can fix
your code or find the old version of
lattice say use the NLM e package for
fitting nonlinear mixed effects models
and when you ran it before everything
went fine you showed the results to your
boss or you publish it as research the
model convergence criteria everything
worked ok you come back and try agree
round a year later and something has
changed underneath and Ellen NME and
suddenly it's complaining about model
convergence I guess something changed in
there and how they are fitting the
parameters and this makes you feel
pretty uncomfortable suddenly the
environment used to produce the results
before you can't reproduce that with
this new environment of the updated
version of NLM e another one is not
every R package you use is going to be
on cran
or github or an external repository say
you got it from collaborators who put it
and they just share it through email or
you got on a USB stick from someone you
really don't want to have to go and hunt
that back down it'd be really nice if we
were able to just keep that package in a
project and save it over time so impact
that helps us solve this problem by one
we make sure that packaged sources are
stored alongside your project and we
track the package version so that you
know if you update our but you need to
return to an old version of a our
project you can roll back and reinstall
that package for some reason so the way
I like to think about it is packrat lets
you build this sandbox in which an
analysis can run and it helps you ensure
that this sandbox will persist over time
and as I said before one of the benefits
but also problems with the current
system for our packages is that
everything gets installed into a global
library so all projects on your system
have access to the same library but for
a particular version of our only one
version of a particular package can be
installed at a time this is problematic
if you have multiple projects on your
system and one depends on a current
version of the package they are sleepy
and other one depends on a newer version
of RC VP which maybe doesn't work with
your older one but you want to leverage
the features of that for new projects so
we want to be able to isolate these
package dependencies for each project
and packrat helps us do that so packrat
does this by giving each project its own
private packrat library so if you don't
know what a library is in our part lungs
a library is just a folder of installed
our packages so when you make a call to
the library function which is kind of
poorly named because it loads a package
from a library say we use library deep
layer to load the deep fire package from
the library r will attempt to load deep
fire by default from that global library
if you use packrat imagine our project
on the other hand packrat will ensure
that our loads that package from a
private library instead the other nice
thing is because we do it this way with
pak-rat it doesn't interfere with any
normal workflows any calls to installed
about packages dev tools install github
by OC light if you're a bioconductor
person these will also get installed
into the private library so you can
ensure that installing new packages for
one project does not break any analysis
you have for another project and because
Patrick collects all of these project
dependencies and it ensures that is
portable across different systems so if
you're working with collaborators you
can ensure everyone working on a bigger
project is using the same version of NER
packages your project depends on so you
don't have to worry about oh you're
getting a bug is it because you have the
newest version I'm using this different
version of this package when people
collaborate on a packer project you
ensure everyone works in the same
environment
all of these things are bet they're done
with the demo so I'll switch to our
studio we can get rid of that so let's
start a new project in our studio so
with the latest our studio daily builds
we have really nice Packer integration
so the first thing you'll see is let me
go back if I go to start a new project
from a new directory an empty project we
now have this new tab use packrat with
this project so let's say I'll make a
new project of called omlettes because I
want to analyze different ways of making
omelets so I do this packrat does some
work to set up the project here and our
studio lists and we have a new project
so we're in the omelets project and
everything looks the same as before
the only thing that is slightly
different now if we go over to the
packages pane will see that we now
have to libraries to places where our
packages live we have the packrat
library and we have the system library
so what we have done is we've isolated
any dependencies and everything we
install is now going to live in this
packrat library let's say I want to use
string R for some bit of code that I'm
running here so first of all I don't
have string it might have been in my
user library but because I'm using
packrat that library is hidden from us
so we're going to go and make sure that
we install it
and notice that it gets put right into
our packrat library so we have string
are from cran version zero point six
point two and you might have seen that
packrat immediately took that and said
oh I see you installed a package string
R I'm going to track that I'm gonna
track it source and so I need to have
this package in your library and you
have string are in your pack rat private
library so now we can use string or you
can call stir see E of C if I want to
concatenate strings great I can use
string are there similarly let's say I
want to install say deep liar so deep
liar has a large number of dependencies
so I'll take a little bit of time to get
that but fortunately we're just
downloading or it will take a little bit
of time to install so let's say we don't
want to wait for that
I guess I can't plus there oh I'll let
it keep going yeah so you see as the
packages are installed you're getting
packrat to track them so now these
packages are tracked in our packrat
library and sorry I'll go and get do you
fire once more the initial bump of
getting the packages in your packrat
library is a little bit slow but it's
worth having your project reproducible
over time I'll just write some code
making use of deep fire apologies for
the wait while it compiles deep liar
okay when we're getting a few questions
about the size of the packrat
repositories can you come and join a big
you'd expect these to get so with
packrat repositories yes they will grow
in size because you keep all of your
package sources and you keep a library
of packages for each private or for each
packrat project so they do get a little
bit bigger but by default if you want to
rebuild or share a packrat project all
you need is the packrat lock file so you
just need to you'll see there's this
packrat dot lock file which tells you
what version of a package you have and
what its source was and so if you trade
that around that's all people need to
share and restore a package so so now
suppose I call packrat status it tells
me that everything is up to date now
suppose I remove a package that my
project depends on say I removed applier
now so notice how in this file here I'm
calling D pliers so I have my project
needs D plier to run and our studio will
go and say hey you're using deep fire in
your project I saw it was removed but
you're using it so I think you probably
want it in your library so it instructs
you to update the library
it tells you that these packages change
in pak-rat
and you can use restore to apply these
changes which restores the library based
on the state of your pak-rat lock file
or the last snapshot so we do that we
see that a call is made to pak-rat
restore so restore takes the last
consistent state of your project and
applies it to the library so it's
reinstalling the prior from cran and
unfortunately compiling from source so
it's a bit slow normally if you're
running a cran build of our this won't
be a problem but the point is here that
pak-rat tracked to deep liar it knew
what version it was it knew where to get
it and so it can go out grab the package
and install it or install it from local
sources as all the packrat package
sources get cached as well so we also
see that you know if we didn't have
access to the Internet in DD prior we
have the exact package sources for deep
liar version 0.2 to use as well one of
the things that we saw earlier was we
have this idea of what is known by
pak-rat which is shown in this column
here and what is currently in your
library which is right here and normally
you have the action packrat snapshot for
taking the state of your library and
applying it into the pak-rat lock file
so you say I want to preserve the
current state of my library over time
and packrat restore for taking the state
of the last consistent library state and
applying it to your library but right
now because we're a consistent state
both of those actions do nothing one
thing the two things you need to know
about to use pak-rat is the snapshot the
current state the current consistent
state of your projects are dependencies
and the private library of packages that
power your project so we have two main
verbs for interacting with these two
components
packrat snapshot records the packaged
versions used by a project and downloads
there so stored with for storage with
the project
and tack wreck restore applies the
previous snapshot to a project building
packages from source as necessary so
once you have your project in a
consistent state you want to save the
current state of the world use packrat
status to do that if you want to restore
that previous state and say you've
removed packages or you receive
something from a collaborator use
restore to restore the library so I went
through that demo so we saw these in net
to initialize a packrat project
packrat saves the current save your
library to the lock file restore
restores the lock file to the library we
saw this on the our studio new package
call we call snapshot it takes the
currency of the library saves it to the
lock file and we call restore if we've
lost those packages it restores them
based on the state of the log file now I
didn't show it in the demo but we can of
course use packages from github so we
have a packrat function or dev tools
function for installing actors from
github say we want to use the
development version of our CPP we can do
that and we would get the development
version which if we had a previous
version from cran we'd see that pack Rab
is upgrading it from the cran zero point
eleven point two to the development zero
point eleven point two point one the
last thing we can do that makes it easy
to share project as we have bundle and
unbundle so bundle packages up every
file within a project along with the
parts of the packrat ecosystem that are
necessary to rebuild the project and you
have control over whether you want to
include the paddock sources or the
package library which you usually want
it don't want to do you want to rebuild
that on other systems if necessary but
you can include the sources if you want
to happen locally for the rebuild
you know the thing is we expect packrat
to work nicely with version control so
the packrat lock file keeps the last
consistent library state but if you're
tracking a project with github you can
track that lock file over time and so
you can roll back to any state from a
lock file within that project if you
need to main goals or objectives of that
rat is to create a nice little
environment for your art projects to run
and live in and keep that reproducible
over time and we want to make it as easy
as possible to use both from packrat and
for from our studio to manage your our
dependencies over time and of course
right now we only match our package
dependencies but there are also other
software for managing entire operating
systems or environments for example
docker if you're interested in that and
so currently packrat is not yet on cran
it is only available on github so if you
want to install the latest version of
packrat you can close this project so we
leave packrat temporarily and if you
have the dev tools package you can
install it with a call to dev tools
install github and so that'll go and
grab it and install it so now you have
it available for use with any projects
on your machine well with that thank you
very much for joining us on the
reproducibility webinar and we'll be
here to answer any questions that you
have about Jeffie ways or my
presentation we have we had a number of
questions in JJ and others have been
very active answering them maybe there
are a couple that are worth trying to
answer very quickly because there were
sort of themes so one of them Kevin was
how does this support what if you put
about if you're using different versions
of our now what's the relay so packrat
does record the version of our you know
library so I'll go back quickly to that
home let's package
so unfortunately packrat doesn't do the
grunt work of finding the version of our
for you but we do record it and so if
someone is using a different version of
our and they try to open your packrat
project packrat will warn them and
unfortunately we don't find our and
install it for them but they know that
oh this project was using this version
of our I should probably go and find it
just so I ensure that the environment
matches that the project was built in
great thanks hey and going back to you
Jeff at the very beginning a number of
questions you know anytime you're
talking about outputs that the the
program that controls those outputs has
a lot of functionality like word or or
even PDFs and so there were some
questions I raised one in particular
what about interactivity in PDF
documents alright Jeff I can't hear you
can you hear me yeah yeah there's no
interactivity doesn't work within PDF
documents because the interactivity is
really that's a web application that's
running inside the browser and the PDF
document isn't able to host a web
application yes and and they were
similar you know some questions about
you know word and tracking changes and
and you know there are there are details
here that matter and you'll want to read
the documentation it's not know
yeah the website are markdown that are
studio.com has a ton of details about
all the formats and what you know what
features are supported what works what
doesn't work and as we hit the hour here
last question I would call out the
differences between it because not only
a vice did I see it on this session but
I also saw I've heard about it from
others but sort of yeah you went
undercover or somebody want to cover the
difference we knit our and our MD and
are in our markdown okay so I didn't
actually mention the other document
promise that neither supports actually
in the very beginning knitter started
with the document format called RW which
basically means the combination of our
and later and but as time goes on people
seem seem to be interested in in Martin
much more interested in Martin's death
so actually if if you are comfortable
with Leigh tank or raw HTML you are free
to write these kinds of documents yeah
for the are mocked on document for the
are mocked on package is basically a
wrapper for the knitter package and the
the pen doc converter okay thanks and
I'm certain we're out of time I'll just
throw it out to you guys it was there
anything you wanted to you know any any
issue that came up in the Q&A s that you
wanted to call out here that we have an
opportunity to say it to the group okay
so I didn't pick something you thought
was important all right folks we thank
you very much for attending today we'd
love for you to check out our all of our
products on our website you can see here
are some links to our evaluation
products for a commercial shiny server
Pro and in our studio server Pro
products we certainly appreciate you
looking at those and and with that we'll
call it a webinar and look forward to
seeing you on September 3rd
[Music]